now y'all are just playing with this one
this is not a real person this is not a
real name
i'm gonna be honest i don't think i'm
gonna do that well
how am i gonna do well pretty damn
terrible
i'm really into celebrity pop culture so
i should probably
know all of this information i think i'm
gonna do pretty good
i don't have a reason to think that but
sometimes you have a hunch
and hunches don't lie stephanie joanne
angelina germanotta you know you're in
trouble when you're not even sure how to
pronounce it
i don't know who that is
it seems italian i don't know if that
helps me angelina jolie
this is like becky g is it snooky
for some reason i'm thinking lady gaga
lady gaga
oh my god this is awkward sorry gaga i
love you
aubry graham that one sounds really
familiar
um asap rocky cardi b
it's a guy we all know that aubry graham
is drake wait this is drake i knew this
no
people know that ashley franjopani these
are so hard wow
i don't know how to say that last name i
don't think i'm gonna get any of these
people
can i get a hint a singer maybe it's
ashley
tisdale is ashley from mary kade
nationally i'm just gonna move on i give
up on ashley
oh it's rosie duh see i've heard one
halsey song i wouldn't have known that
catherine elizabeth hudson kate hudson
kate hudson kate hudson it's not kate
hudson
it's definitely a katie katy perry yes
okay that one makes sense that was my
bad abel mcconan
tesfaye i don't know it's not ti is it
andy cohen is it andy cohen i'm gonna
assume it's an r b
singer acon this is my one right answer
that's the weekend jelena nour hadid
okay well we know this is a hadid but
which hadid can i say bella hadid
because
she probably was like i'm pretty i'm
going to call myself bella it's bella
honey
all right i'm just going to have to go
gigi gigi jolena gigi
oh is there another hadid
it starts with an n and it ends with a g
so maybe it's nate dog
she's an actress oh she's an actress
natalie
portman hey wow robin
fenty i want to say because robin is
spelled that way that it's the singer
robin
robin finty okay that's rihanna serena
that's her real name i have so many
questions amala
ratna zendali dil mini i'm sorry if i
butchered that
is that zendaya is it zendaya i know who
this is this is my girl dogicat
oh doji cat my cat's name is actually
doja
belsalis this feels vaguely familiar to
me
i've heard this one before definitely a
rapper gucci mane
is it nicki minaj cardi b is it cardi b
all right cardi b i can see why you
changed it peter gene hernandez
i don't know he just sounds like a
regular guy to me as a singer
yeah that's helpful the only square i
can start on is that hernandez suggests
latinx male george lopez
bruno mars onika mirage i knew someone
named onika once
i'm just gonna try and channel her
personality i just have no idea actually
truly
nicki minaj nicki minaj nicki minaj
oh wow that's so obvious
austin richard post little richard
i don't know no idea oh post malone
postman there we go okay austin i see
you
nevadius damon wilburn i mean i'm
thinking neo
because nevadius maybe could be
shortened to neo honestly i wouldn't
have changed this name
is it lil wayne is it snoop dogg oh
feature i think i did okay i should have
done
better i probably did very middle of the
road
i guess in reality i got two i think i
need to educate myself further is what i
learned from this video
but honestly i would like to see you
guys do this you probably wouldn't have
known half of them
maybe my stage name would be one of
these real names should i
like have my stage name be onika mirage
[Music]
you